[Music]
and welcome everybody to Long Prime
daily I'm Jesse Weber Harvey Weinstein
the disgrace movie Mogul already
convicted of rape in New York is now a
convicted sexual predator on both coasts
on Monday after 10 days of deliberation
a jury in Los Angeles County found
Weinstein guilty of three sex crimes in
connection with the Russian Italian
model jurors acquitted Weinstein of
another crime and they deadlocked on the
remaining three jurors returned to the
courthouse on Tuesday morning to hear
about aggravating factors that could
impact Weinstein's sentencing now he's
already serving a 23-year sentence for
sex crimes convictions in New York his
legal team has filed an appeal but this
latest conviction in California all but
guarantees that Weinstein will never get
out of prison because of the mixed
verdict Weinstein faces between 18 and
24 years behind bars right now he's 70
years old one of the decisions the jury
deadlocked on was the case of Jane Doe
number two identifying as Lauren Young
she testified in LA and New York serving
as a prior bad ax witness in Weinstein's
first trial Young's attorney Gloria
Allred says she's prepared to testify a
third time if she has to part of a
statement from Young was read after the
verdict
I'm so grateful that I had the chance to
tell the truth about what happened to me
back in 2013.
I am relieved that Harvey Weinstein has
been convicted because he deserves to be
punished
for the crimes that he committed and he
can no longer use his power to
intimidate and sexually assault more
women
after the New York City trial a pandemic
a baby
and this Los Angeles trial
I can finally put this traumatic memory
to rest it will be for the prosecutor to
make that decision as to whether he will
retry
the count for Lauren Young
and uh
will await that decision
all right I'm here with co-host and
former trial Attorney Terry Austin Terry
first he's convicted in New York then
he's convicted in California but do the
cases have any impact on each other oh
they definitely impacted each other so
the two cases I think are you know held
in different states obviously and they
involved different accusers Weinstein's
already as you mentioned serving the 23
years in New York but he appealed that
verdict and the New York Court of
Appeals agreed to hear the case which
means there was at least one reasonable
appellate issue now the California
conviction is significant because even
if the New York conviction is overturned
Weinstein still faces those 24 years
behind bars in California his attorneys
have said they're going to appeal that
too but assuming both convictions are
upheld Weinstein would likely serve out
his sentence in New York and then serve
the second sentence in California so of
course both parties could agree where
they're going to serve that sentence and
you know statistically speaking as you
mentioned he's 70 years old likelihood
he will not serve two full sentences
yeah definitely not good Brian so I'm
here with Brian buckmeyer for our other
co-host and public defender he's likely
going to appeal California's verdict is
that going to be successful it is a long
shot to say the least but I do think he
has some arguments here I think he's
going to look at this as a situation
where yeah he's convicted based on one
of the accusers but the others was a
mixed bag and then you have these prior
bad act Witnesses for him he's going to
look at the glass kind of half uh full
so to speak and he's going to probably
say hey if these other Bad actors in
intestify maybe the one and only victim
who convicted him might have not had a
conviction I don't know but for him to
be able to win an appeal in in
California then again in New York it's a
long shot but I can see him putting all
of his resources towards it yeah he was
really banking I'm sure on not getting
convicted in California because he was
hoping that the New York conviction
would be overturned not a great day for
Harvey Weinstein moving over to Ohio on
Monday George Wagner IV learned his fate
in connection into the 2016 Pike County
Massacre now Wagner was convicted of
aggravated murder after a trial that
lasted months during the sentencing
hearing a family member of one of the
eight victims told Wagner quote I hope
you burn in hell prosecutors considered
members of the rodent and Gilly families
to be collateral damage in a child
custody battle between Wagner's brother
Jake and victim Hannah Rhoden Jake and
their mother Angela testified against
Wagner after pleading guilty to avoid
the death penalty but the patriarch of
the family George Billy Wagner still
faces his own trial as for George Wagner
IV well he was given eight consecutive
life sentences plus
121 years for the eight victims that
were killed
Wells Fargo was slapped with another
record-breaking fine to settle claims
that it was part of banking violations
that harmed millions of consumers on top
of a 1.7 billion dollar fine the bank
agreed to pay another 2 billion dollars
in Damages the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau says that the bank
misapplied customer payments on loans
wrongfully repossessed cars and homes
and charged overdraft fees even when
customers didn't overdraw their accounts
well the bank has already started to
repay some of the customers much of that
two billion dollars in Damages is going
to go towards further fixing accounts
including repaying more than 200 million
dollars in overdraft fees alone the
money continues this week in the case of
Tory Lanez a Canadian rapper accused of
shooting fellow rapper Megan the
stallion prosecutors called 80 a D.A
investigator Jody little to the stand on
Monday and little did the September
interview with Kelsey Harris which was
played in full for the jury last week
Harris's Megan's former assistant and
friend who was with her in Lanes in 2020
when Lanes allegedly shot at or near
Megan's feet injuring her the
prosecution asked little about a diss
track that was put out by Harris after
the shooting some of the song lyrics
mentioned the incident which happened
after a get-together at Kylie Jenner's
home while Harris told the District
Attorney's Office in September that she
saw Lane shoot Megan she backtracked
once she was on the witness stand now
Brian it seems to me that the
prosecution wanted to know about the
diss track they could have asked Kelsey
Harris about it when she was on the
stand absolutely Jesse bringing in this
testimony this way just baffles the mind
of many Defense series The song is
called busing back it was a diss Track
by Kelsey Harris to Megan the stallion
seemingly in response to their Fallout
after the shooting and the prosecution
is trying to use it as a confession
using rap lyrics at trial is
controversial to say the least
especially when prosecutors pick and
choose what they use and this isn't the
first time lyrics have made headlines
we've heard about Young Thug in his case
in Georgia don't need to go over that
again but here using lyrics seems absurd
the judge let the prosecution use a
distract of a witness who is already on
the stand to try to prove a fact they
could have gone from her well she was
under the oath when she testified not
when she rapped when she said if I was
the one with the Ghana you would have
heard about a murder it's not a
confession put her on the stand ask her
the questions and that's a proper way to
do this well Terry the jury watched the
entire 80-minute interview of Harris and
then they saw her testify in the stand
what do you think they're thinking liar
liar pants on fire is what I think
they're thinking she was just so
different in her demeanor when she did
that interview she was cool calm and
collected she seemed as though she was
telling the truth she was very credible
but when she got on that witness stand
she hemmed she hauled she hesitated she
couldn't complete any thought and it did
seem as though she was trying to change
her story and if I'm that jury and I'm
listening to her and I'm comparing that
to how she was when she did that
interview I would conclude that the
interview was more credible and in fact
the judge will will give a charge on
credibility and they can just throw our
entire testimony out are we ever getting
any answers to what really happened I'm
not sure I'm not sure all said and done
at the end of this job we're really
going to know what happened between the
two or between the three I should say